[Music]
okay thank you very much so you know
yesterday I talked about nearest
neighbors and you know some some of the
more basic and classical stuff about
classification and regression today I'm
going to change tracks a little bit and
I'm going to talk about some new stuff
we have been doing on nearest neighbors
and adversarial examples and you know
also you know more general adversarial
examples more generally adversarial
examples for nonparametric s-- so if
this was you know again this was
yesterday today we are going to change
tracks a little bit okay so what are
adverse ADL examples you know you guys
have I'm sure you guys have seen this
demo you have an image of a panda you
have a neural network who's absolutely
confident it's a panda and then you add
this right point zero zero seven times
this and you know to you it looks like a
panda and two we know I guess to all of
us it looks like a panda but now your
neural network is super confident that
this is a given right so and you know I
mean this is not the only demo you have
seen many such demos like you know like
stop signs you put stickers on it and
then suddenly cars think it's an eel
sign and you know all this other stuff
right so that's that's adverse alien
examples and you know I am sure I'm
missing out a whole bunch of citations
here you know Sega D at all 2013
Goodfellow does this particular
particular picture is from the good
fellow at all 2014 paper one interesting
thing is that actually these kinds of
attacks were considered by Kris Meeke
and Danny allowed way back in 2005 so
it's actually pretty old then it has
seen a resurgence recently but you know
so those are adversarial examples right
and you don't there's another example
you know you will see stop signs like
this and burfi quite a bit you know stop
war and then if you have a self-driving
car it will mistake this as a you know
sign or something else right and what is
going on over here is you have some sort
of test input and you slightly modify it
right so you know to to a human this
looks like you know it's basically
imperceptibly slight right like it's a
slight modification and then what
happens is this causes misclassification
right the other interesting thing is
that not only is this a slight
modification it's a strategic
modification right so if you just do a
random slight modification of your stop
sign your classified will be fine but if
you do a modification in some specific
strategic direction then this is not
going to be the case anymore and you
know many classifiers are vulnerable to
adversarial examples like you know a lot
of neural networks even some classical
things like you know nearest neighbors
and decision trees there they're really
vulnerable and kind of the current state
of the art is that there are many many
many attacks there are many defenses
which you know tend to be broken every
so often and there are also a whole
bunch of certifiable defenses which
prove that you know things are
certifiable there is some understanding
on how widest examples exist and however
that's somewhat limited right so you
know I know Sebastian gave a really nice
talk on this but to some extent some of
this is understood not all of it is well
understood why this example success so
what we are going to do today is we are
going to you know I just I told you what
adversarial examples are we are going to
start out with a statistical learning
framework for robustness and then I'm
going to tell you a little bit about the
adversarial examples for nearest
neighbors and then we will look beyond
nearest neighbors to more general
nonparametric okay so remember yesterday
I talked about the statistical learning
framework and you know just keep nearest
neighbor in mind when you are looking at
this framework where you have this
metric space so it's an instance there
is X and s this distance or this metric
D and there is some underlying measure
on mu on X from which the points are
drawn right so your X is tend to get
drawn from the
and elimination meal and the label of X
is a coin flip so think about so for now
we are thinking about binary labels
although the analysis you know bit a bit
of messy math will translate in general
but you know let's think about this as
binary just to keep things clean so the
label of X is a coin flip whose bias is
at of X where it affects is basically
probability y equal to 1 given X right
and in the statistical learning
framework what we are hoping to do is
you're hoping to get you know what we
care about is the accuracy right so the
accuracy of a classifier f is the
fraction of times f of X agrees with Y
right and when I say fraction or a
probability what I mean is this
probability is over this mu times at a
distribution right when X is Rhon from
you and y is drawn from Etta
you know Y given X or rather y given X
is drawn from Etta
so the fraction of times the prediction
of F on X agrees with Y that is the
accuracy and in the statistical learning
framework what we you know what we
always hope to do is find classifiers
which have high accuracy okay okay so
now let us look at what happens when we
also throw the sort of robustness into
the mix and let's start out with some
definitions okay so we define the
robustness radius of a classifier F at a
particular point X is the distance to
the closer Z such that f of X is not
equal to f of z right so basically the
closest distance you have to go so that
the label of the classifier changes
right and you know very natural
definition we are going to sometimes use
this definition and we are going to
denote it by Rho of F X right and this
will differ vary from X to X okay so
this is the robustness radius it will
vary from X to X and high robustness
radius means that your classifier is
going to be really robust in its X right
at this particular point is going to be
very robust
okay so we have talked about robustness
radii but the thing to notice is that
the absolute measure of robustness is
actually not that interesting because if
you have a constant classified it's
going to be robust everywhere so you
don't necessarily want your classifier
to be robust everywhere what you want is
you want you classify to be robust at
interesting inputs right and the baby
model interesting inputs in statistical
learning theory is through a
distribution so what we care about is
robust nests with respect to your
distribution and and we can define this
thing okay yes how would you want to
define the distance to the bomb yes so
here it would be probably zero yeah
according to this definition is it
excellent question yes we have a little
bit it'll probably be zero
so the robustness of a classifier at
radius R with respect to this underlying
distribution is the you know basically
the fraction of points at which the
robust this radius is greater than equal
to R right and this high robustness with
respect to this distribution implies
that you know this high value of R
implies that high robustness on inputs
from this distribution
okay and with these now we can talk
about you know algorithms and robustness
of algorithms let's say you have a
training data set S sub n which fits
into an algorithm a and what comes out
is a classifier a of S sub n then the
distribution and robustness of this
algorithm a at radius R is this
robustness of a of s n so the classifier
produced by this algorithm at radius R
with respect to me will remember Mew was
our underlying distribution and X and
let's say the expectation of this as
limit n goes to infinity right size
limit n goes to infinity what happens to
this you know this robustness metric
with respect to this distribution we can
also talk about you know finite sample
robustness basically you know what
happens to this expectation for finite n
okay and now so you know so far we have
talked about robustness there is also
you know your constant classifier is
always robust right so whenever you talk
about the robust classifier there has to
be some discussion of accuracy right
some sort of combining robustness and
accuracy and what we do is you know we
proposed this measure called in which we
call astuteness which combines
robustness and accuracy and you know
it's it's not just so we call we we came
up with the name a stiffness but other
people have actually also come across
this measure independently so there's a
paper by citrus at all
20 I think I clear 20 19 they have also
looked at this particular measure right
so what does a stiffness tell you so the
acid nurse of a classifier at a certain
radius R is basically the fraction so
remember accuracy was the fraction of
points where the classifier was right a
stiffness is the fraction of points
where the classifier is right and it's
robust right so you know not only is it
right but it's also robust right so it's
like you know really quite sharp and or
astute or whatever so so so this would
be if your robustness radius was R this
would be a point where it's astute if
your robustness area bizarre if you were
over here then the classifier won't be
asked to do over there because it's
correct but it's not robust right
and and basically what we want to kind
of do is if you want to do robust
learning one you know a bowl that we
care about is maximizing this sort of
bastion so we fix our ahead of time and
what we care about is you know
maximizing as goodness and we can look
at things like you know of course again
like just like robustness we can look at
distribution elastic nails and finite
sample as students and you know we can
define it in a particular way but
usually that you know in in a similar
way
okay so prior work so there has been
again I should note that this is like
theoretical prior work so there has been
a lot of prior word a lot of theoretical
prior work you know other than ours on
adversarial examples for parametric
methods for example Smith it all talked
about linear classifier and showed that
you know robustness requires more data
Sebastian gave a talk earlier in this
program talking about computational
issues and there's been also a bunch of
others like in a tall and want to set at
all and I'm sure I'm missing some
because this is a very fast-growing area
where you know adversarial
generalization bounds have been given
okay and what we have been looking at is
and and you know the way our work is
somewhat different is that we've been
interested in nonparametric methods and
how they respond to adversarial examples
okay okay
so so let's so so let's let's get to
that okay so in particular you know
we've been interested in nearest
neighbors and we started looking at when
its nearest neighbors robust to
adversarial examples and here is
something that we could show so what
happens with one nearest neighbors right
so what we can show is the following if
your mu remember me is the distribution
over X if your mu is continuous and if
in a neighborhood of X your eta is not
zero or one right so it lies somewhere
between zero and one then the robustness
radius at X basically just converges to
zero as n grows right and what does this
imply well basically what this implies
is that the distributional robot
someone nearest-neighbor you know at
these points it's just basically zero
right and and you know and of course as
students as well right so the
distribution of robust at this point is
basically zero as n goes to infinity
you know the robustness radius actually
decreases right and this is somewhat in
contrast with accuracy which still might
be high right if your ETA is like 0.99
your accuracy might still be pretty high
because your accuracy will converge to
twice at a times 1 minus error but
you're you know distribution and
robustness won't be right your
distribution and robustness would really
go to zero and here is some proof
intuition which is also you know not
super duper hard to see so what's gonna
happen over here right so what's gonna
happen is that as n grows as you get
more and more points if you look at a
ball of radius R right you have your X
and you have a ball of radius R around X
if it is not exactly 0 or 1 this ball
will have some point which has a
different label than X right so if your
X's label was 1 you will get at least a
point which label is 0 and this point is
an adversarial example because if you
place a test point right at that that's
going to be its nearest neighbor and
that's it
right so you know so you go for one
nearest neighbors you can't really
expect it to be robust at all and the
similar argument will also hold for
constant kids so they're you know you
have to look at majorities and stuff
like that you know things have to be a
little bit more complicated but it will
still hold for constantly
if you still apply but n has to be very
large okay so if your n is you know it
you're absolutely right so you will
probably need n that is exponential in
the dimension right because then your
points have to come closer and closer
but this as n goes to infinity the limit
will still be zero anymore patience
so this this is all so is this like
saying that the really the best robust
classifier that you can help like will
have like robustness you know excellent
question
so so in these regions what I'm saying
is in these regions if you use KD
receiver with constant K as n grows and
grows that robustness will converge to
zero
even though that's not the case for
accuracy okay so fine so we looked at
constant K and you know in constant K
the accuracy is not sometimes not too
bad but you know robustness is you know
not that great right so what happens but
you know what happens with larger K
right can we ever get robustness and
let's remind ourselves what happens with
K nearest neighbor and accuracy you know
which we kind of talked about yesterday
so yesterday what we talked about what
we showed was that as n goes to infinity
the risk of one nearest neighbor
converges to something like this right
twice expectation over X twice Etta x
times one minus ed X as n goes to
infinity and this is you know and what
we pointed out is that this is more than
the Bayes optimal risk right so remember
Bayes optimal was our you know kind of
gold standard classifier and this is a
for accuracy and this was more than the
Bayes optimal risk right and be sure to
in in some sense this was inconsistent
right inconsistent in the sense that it
doesn't converge to the risk of the
Bayes optimal and what we showed was
that Kenan is also inconsistent for
constant K right and then what we showed
was that if ki
however if King grew within so if K went
to infinity as n went to infinity and K
over N went to zero at the same time
right then you know things went things
were more and more local your predictor
became more and more local and Cavin to
infinity then the risk of K nearest
neighbor would converge to there is not
the Bayes optimal right said this is
something we could show so we could you
know we showed that when K grows in a
certain manner then things are actually
not that bad he said this was something
we talked about yesterday okay so if you
talk about the robustness of K nearest
neighbor what can you really expect
right if your kea grows your key nearest
neighbor converges sudha B is optimal so
you know it's robust regions what should
converge the robust region of the Bayes
optimal right we can't really expect
anything better right that's not gonna
magically happen right so so the
question is okay so that
the best thing we could expect so let's
look at where the Bayes optimal is
robust yeah so so we are going to do
that and since I know this is a theory
talk let me start out by defining some
notation okay so it is probability y
equal to 1 given X right so if it is
exactly 0 then you know you need it get
away from 0 by some constant oh I see
bounded over from 0 by some constant I
see I see I forgot a good question yeah
that's a good question I think we use
that in the proof but I'm not a hundred
percent sure that we need it we use it
in the proof that it is bounded away
from zero you're right but I'm not a
hundred percent sure you need it because
it is for one year is never you just
need one point in that ball of radius R
right one point with a different label
okay so good good question excellent so
now yes so let's let's get back to this
and so let me start out with some
definition so again you know it's a
definition that we used you know we
talked about yesterday as well the
probability mass so the definition that
we are going to talk about is balls of
probability masses right because
remember from yesterday when you talk
about nearest neighbors it's you know
the right abstraction to look at our
balls of certain probability masses
right so the probability radius of a
ball so our P of X so here P is a number
between 0 & 1 so P is a probability it's
essentially the radius where this ball
has probability mass P right and you
know this this looks a little bit
complicated so forget about the ins and
so on because you know Eva needed to get
things to work out and stuff like that
but essentially what this is our P of X
is the radius of the ball where hoots
probability mass is just P right so
that's that's all that is right so this
is our P of X balls of probability
radius and then now once we have these
probability radiuses we can now define
something called robust interiors right
is that sort of analogous to what we
defined yesterday which were the actual
you know which were the interiors but
this is actually a little bit stronger
right so what is the robust interior so
now we have three parameters R P and
Delta right and what does this mean so
it's all points X such that if you look
at all X Prime in a ball of radius R
around X and if you look at this X prime
and a ball a probability it must be
right there had everything in these
union would have it greater than equal
to half plus depth right so if you
remember P is a probability parameter
right and Delta is you know like a
margin parameter right yesterday we
talked about this half plus minus Delta
AI Delta is like a margin parameter and
P is like a probability parameter and
what you want here is you look at X you
look at balls of radius R around X and
you look at every point in these balls
and if you look at balls of probability
mass appear on those points then in all
these balls the data is great it as you
know py given X is strictly greater than
1/2 plus Delta right and so this is the
positive part and similarly you can also
define the negative part of these robust
and tedious and then you can look at you
know the RP delta interiors would be the
union of the positive and the negative
right so what I'd like to point out a
couple of things over here right so one
thing to notice is that unlike
yesterday's definition so yes sir this
definition was more in terms of averages
right and which is good when you are
talking about accuracy you just want the
average to work out right this
definition is actually for all right so
there's a for all over here right for
all X prime X double prime and for all X
prime and unfortunately for robustness
you know that's kind of important
because of a personal definition
involves so far all right so you have to
get that right the other thing to notice
is that there is also this parameter R
right which was not their mission and
you know you just kind of need this
parameter R because you want things to
be just sort of uniform do to kind of
converge to the same label in a radius
in a ball of radius R ok so now let's
get back to where the Bayes optimal is
robust what you can show is that the
Bayes optimal has robustness radius R in
these in in this particular interior
right so the positive interior with
parameters R 0 0 Union the negative
interior with parameters R 0 and this is
you know follows mostly from the
definition you know the trick is setting
up the definitions properly and then you
can also set up a stiffness right so you
can talk about a stiffness and its you
know what you would expect it to be this
is you know ETA x times this you know
this is the this is where its robust
robustly positive and then
is the probability which it's positive
plus this is very robustly negative it
doesn't very robustly negative enters
the problem given business name so once
you set up the definition this is quite
easy
oh yes so the zero here is the
probability right the ball of so 1 0 is
ball of probability P so that P is 0 and
the other 0 is the the margin Delta so
this is the limit object so these things
are nonsense
ok what about K and virus names so here
is something that we could show suppose
we have like a parameter Delta and the
margin parameter that goes to 0 if K n
grows in this particular way and the
growth is square root DN log n divided
by Delta n and your P and I you know
it's like a complicated expression but
you know think about it like this right
ok n over n plus times 1 plus something
right one plus you know maybe something
else less than a constant then with high
probability care nearest neighbors and
high probability there is a 1 minus
Delta which is hidden in various
constants which I'm not gonna go into K
nearest neighbors has robustus radius at
least R in this following pigeon right
so the interior with radius R are the
probability parameters P sub n the
margin parameters Delta sub n Union the
negative interior with radius R
probability parameter P sub N and margin
parameter Delta and so there's a couple
of comments over here so first is that
this is actually much faster than
required for accuracy right so of course
I mean if you also want accuracy then
your key n over N has to also go to 0
right so that's just you know that's
just given right so I'm not gonna go
into that so that's just sort of given
but the thing to note is is that for K n
for accuracy all you needed was KN to go
to infinity right and this is a much
faster rate of growth right square root
DN log n is 0 pretty fast right so this
is a much faster rate of growth okay so
this is you know something to note and
we don't actually have any bounds of
what happens and we
twin so you know yeah I don't know much
faster rate of growth okay the second
thing to notice is if your P n goes to
European is approximately K n over N if
that goes to 0 and if your delta n also
goes to 0 then this quantity right this
interior you know under various
regularity conditions of course then
this interior will also go to the robust
region of the Bayes optimal right so
then your the interior of our P and
Delta and you know P N and Delta n are
all going to both going to 0 here again
P N and Delta n about going to 0 so
under you know if things are nice and
regular then this this sort of thing
will also go to answers right so
essentially you know under nice
conditions this will also go to the
robustness region of the result if you
let your can grow properly then its
robustness region will go through the
robustness region of the Bayes optimal
and to be honest that's all you can
expect right like K nearest neighbor
converging so the Bayes optimal what
more can you get right it's not
magically gonna be better okay
so let me give you a little bit of proof
intuition so why why does this kind of
thing happen so the magic word over here
or at the magic two words over here is
uniform convergence right and that is
where the D comes from so those of you
in the know you will realize that that
is what the D comes from right so what's
gonna happen over here if your key n is
this big then by uniform convergence
what you're going to have is if you look
at X right and if you look at the
distance to his skin quenette's nearest
neighbor right for all X all together in
the whole world the probability mass of
that ball is going to be you know KN
over n plus minus something small right
so this is approximate this is an
approximate thing but that's essentially
what is gonna happen right and the key
here is for all X okay and now if your X
lies in let's say a positive interior
right then for X double prime sorry if
your X prime lives in a positive
interior then all for X double
prime which is a canid nearest-neighbor
of X this Etta is going to be greater
than half plus Delta n and by uniform
convergence things will just work out
right so the idea here is that your ball
is big enough then you have enough kN
that you are outputting the same thing
as the Bayes optimal which is again the
same by definition of the interiors
which is again the same as the Bayes
optimal in the place that you are
supposed to be robust ok so that's kind
of the idea and for our proof we
actually need uniform convergence I'm
not exactly sure if you always need it
so that's kind of an open question so if
you don't need uniform convergence then
you can bring down the key ok so the
next question is okay so you know this
is well and good but K is really large
and it will take you a long time so can
we get robustness for something like one
nearest neighbor and as it turns out the
answer is actually yes but what you need
is a somewhat modified algorithm so to
do to get to this modified algorithm
let's start out by thinking about when
is Leona sleeper robust right so if you
look at one nearest neighbor when is it
going to be robust at a particular X
well it's gonna be robust when points
with different labels are well separated
and your X is close to a point you know
with the same label right so you have an
x and y it's close to the point with
another X which has the same label Y and
it's far off from point which has a
different label right so the question is
can be artificially do this right so you
remove a subset of the training data
that is basically causing trouble right
so you remove a subset of the training
data so that differently label points of
our part and then you do nearest
neighbors on the remaining data right
and the question is which are the points
that you can remove well you just you
know what points are you going to remove
right like this any kind of subsets that
you could remove so you keep a bunch of
points whose labels you are confident
about and then you keep Bureau a maximal
subset of the rest and then the rest
will be fine okay so
okay so let's now try to formalize this
so to formalize this let me introduce
this notion of our separation so suppose
you have a set of points X I Y I like a
whole bunch of label training points we
say that these are are separated
if points with different labels and at
least distance two are apart okay and
what people do is you know so that's
that's what we mean by separated right
so remember we talked about how you know
points with different labels should be
separated the notion of separation we
are going to use is our separation okay
and then we also talked about we will
keep the points whose labels we are
confident about so how do we get these
confident labels let's look at that
right so here is how we are going to get
confident labels so suppose you have an
input X our training data set of size N
and parameters in a little Delta and big
Delta you set K n to be three log you
know to an over Delta or Delta squared
and you know this is again these are set
to make the Chernoff bound work out as
you can probably tell over Delta square
you look at those many neighbors of X
and average them right and if the
average is between 1/2 minus Delta and
half plus Delta then you say I don't
know because then you are too uncertain
otherwise you round up the little round
of this average annual return right so
basically it's like a simple thing where
if there are you know if you look at
your nearest neighbors if their majority
is too far off from half bounded away
from half you say yes and if the
majority is too close to half then you
say well I don't know okay and here is
the full algorithm for all i f of x i so
you calc you first compute its confident
labels right with parameters little
Delta and big Delta you start out with
an empty set right and this empty said
what you're going to do is you're going
to build up a set of confident points
right and then what you do is if you
have if you're confident label is y and
you're confident label is equal to the
confident label of everybody else in
your vicinity right and and sorry I
should have added that this is not I
don't know right so if you're confident
label
is why if it is equal to the confident
label of everybody else in a ball of
radius R around you and this label is
not I don't know then you add this to
your confidence set points right so you
add this to your fitness set of
confident points and then once you have
those confidence points you're always
going to keep them and then you return
the largest are separated subsets of
your training set that contains these
confident points right so you return
done and that's your training data for
one year it's never ok you just do one
your s neighbor on this so what can we
say about this algorithm so again we can
show something and it's unfortunately
it's a little bit more complicated so
suppose you have this Delta little Delta
which is you know kind of one of these
high probability parameters and suppose
your TN looks like this okay and this is
the KN that we used for our algorithm
writer for the confident labeling
algorithm and your P n is KN over N
times 1 plus something like square root
D over K right so that's that's about
your P n and then we are going to define
this so we are going to choose some
parameter T and we are going to define
the set right so this set is basically
the R plus T interior right the
interiors with parameters R plus T P N
and Delta and the union of the positive
and the negative interiors where the
density is somewhat high right and you
need this somehow at least we need this
kind of high density condition because
if the density is too low then you're
not going to see points from this right
so here the density is high enough that
you end up seeing points from these
regions right so you have so in some
sense this is kind of the high density
subset of the integers right so if you
look at this XR then what we can show is
that with high probability the algorithm
that we just talked about has robustus
radius at least r minus 2t on this
particular set ok so again what does
this mean
your XR is essentially it's a high
density subset of this area or this
region and you know you need the high
density subset because you need to see
some of these algorithms in your
training data that's that's really
motivating this
and then notice that as DPN and Delta
and goes to zero this also you know
under various regularity things are nice
and regular this will also go to the
robust region of the Bayes optimal right
and what we have is the high density
region of this so you know so this will
also you know provided the density is
again high enough then it'll also go to
the robustness region of that okay so
what's going on over here so let me give
you just some brief proof intuition so
what we can show is if your ex I lies in
this interior right in the right
interior and your Y I is the right label
for X I then based on the properties of
K sub n right because K sub n is large
enough you can do large deviations you
can show that you know the right things
will happen and x iy I will get added to
the confidence set right so if your X I
actually lies in the interior and your Y
is the right label it will get added to
the confident side right on the other
hand if you have a particular point test
point in X are by uniform convergence
there will be some X I Y I in your
training set and close to X right so
imagine this is your X there is going to
be some X I in your training set that is
also close to X right and this comes
from the fact that it's in the high
density region right if this was not in
the high density region this training
point may not be there and you may have
made some mistakes right and then from
what we talked about this X I Y I will
actually get added to the final training
set right so if this X I Y I gets added
to the final training set then you are
doing the right thing
now since so what this means is that if
that X is an X I then you are going to
output the right label for it
right on the other hand since your t is
are separated right and you know the
final thing will also be on t and the
final training set is are separated any
xj which
a different label is going to be at
least two are apart from this sorry tore
apart from this X I so this distance is
going to be at least 2 R so this
distance will be at least you know 2 R
minus T and if you have another X prime
which is also going to have the same
label as XJ that distance is going to be
at least you know 2 R minus 2 T right
and so what we can show is that the you
know by various triangle inequality
style arguments what we can show is that
this will give you a radius of at least
our minus 2t right the robustness radius
will it be at least R - ok so so far we
talked about you know this algorithm now
the question is how does it actually
work in practice because you know we
showed various large sample convergence
rates you know in reality we have in
life we have finite samples how does it
work right so we looked at some
experiments we looked at you know
standard one nearest neighbors robust n
n is our method and we looked at you
know two standard adversarially train
nearest neighbor so at that point there
were no other defenses so you know we
looked at adversary train nearest
neighbors and you know we looked at a
few different data sets and so the kind
of attacks we used word so we had a
couple of you know standard baseline
attacks so the one the first one is the
direct attack at the time this was the
only attack known for nearest neighbor
so this is 2018 we are talking about and
so basically the idea is that you find
the closest X Prime in your training set
which has a different label and move a
distance R towards it right and then
there was also something by pepper knew
at all
where basically you find the kernel
classify which is just soft nearest
neighbors and you just attack it with
standard gradient based methods right so
for parametric methods there are you
know just all kinds of gradient based
methods for attacking them so you just
use those ok and these are some of the
attack results so what you see here is
robust tenon is us right so this is the
orange line is ours so in the x-axis
what you have is the max l2 norm of
adversarial perturbation in the y axis
what you have is classified
accuracy right and so if the accuracy
goes down that is not that creative the
accuracy remains up that's kind of a
good thing and what you see is that this
our our the orange light mostly just
stays stays above the rest right and you
know standard nearest neighbor is not
very good and adversarially trained
nearest neighbor which is actually a
very good defense for parametric methods
there is also another line of work on
what are called black box attacks so in
black box attacks what happens is you
know instead of attacking the particular
classifier you build another classifier
on the training data and you attack that
right and the reason you know that is
interesting I mean this is of course a
weaker attack but the reason why that is
interesting is because you know a lot of
parametric defenses early defenses what
they would do is they would mask the
gradient right so they would just
somehow hides the gradient and so the
gradient based attacks for white box
attacks would not work but these lapis
attacks would work extremely well so
it's a weaker attack but it works better
because of you know the way that acts
are constructed right so that's that's
why these are also interesting together
right and so what we see is that the
black box attacks you know everything is
more or less the same and the reason for
this actually so we used to substitute
classifiers so one was the kernel you
know like soft nearest neighbor
classifier and then the other was a
neural network and the reason for this
actually is that black box attacks they
translate very well from one neural
network to another but they don't
translate that well between parametric
and non-parametric and this had been
observed before I mean we are not the
first people to make this observation
this had been observed before but you
know this is just a sanity check
so this corroborates past results past
experimental things I three words
so what yes okay so so what we did was
you know we just you know showed some
robustness properties of nearest
neighbors we talked about a new nearest
neighbor robust nearest neighbor
algorithm and we gave some experimental
results okay so this was
you know kind of the first part of the
time okay yes your defense related to
small thing that I can say at the
Gaussian noise and my test time and look
at the majority of the labels that have
collected from not that I can see not
that I can see but I think it would be
nice to see if there is a connection
okay so yes well almost
you take something black what's it not
that we have seen on our experiments but
I can't remember our reference which
does it
yeah actually probably not so the paper
newspaper probably also shows that I
think I have to look I have to just
double-check that experiment the results
but I mean that is also mine okay so
okay so we talked about nearest nib si
yes so doing that couple slides for the
black box in the bottom you taken a
neural network architecture presently
wants and melts you adversary based on
and missed and evaluate nearest
neighbors if my understanding of this
one so this is a very small l2
perturbation home please considered most
things and emissaries yeah excellent
question so these are normalized did or
what I think they were normalized so
what what is this thing
you know I'll have to look up the exact
details but this is not for big sense
this was normalized so is that what
you're asking any to and thus images are
more than for distance apart in l2 norm
yeah so the fact that like it that's
scaled and the fact that you're getting
all my three percent accuracy even
standard nearest neighbors is entirely
super-surprising sorry Tessa right all
right no I I agree with you but these
were this is not the standard in this
scale so these were normalized I don't
remember the details off off the top of
my head but I can look it up for you
like I mean it's not for pixel's so when
I say four I don't need 4 pics of right
like four okay so now coming back to
right so we talked about nearest
neighbors
the next question is you know can we
just kind of look at more generic
nonparametric sand this is some work
that be that is that that we just tested
and it's you know it's gonna come up and
archive in a few days so the idea is
that can you get genetic attacks and
defenses for nonparametric Slyke nearest
neighbors and decision trees and animals
right so and the reason why we you know
care about this generally thinks is for
parametric methods we don't have
generate things right so we have you
know a lot of gradient based attacks so
there are also other kinds of attacks so
that's why I said most but we do have a
lot of gradient based attacks where you
know remember in parametric models you
get theta star by minimizing a loss
function so the gradient based you start
at some X and then you go up the loss
function until the level changes right
so you know things like fast radiant
sine methods and stuff they are based on
this sort of thing and then there's a
lot of others right but basically this
is kind of the idea right and then kind
of defenses that work are you know what
is called adversarial training a lot of
Defense's are like this so basically
what you do is training with data
augmented with adversarial examples
right then people have been doing this
for a while I think Alex Madras group
has a very nice paper which has offered
some theoretical justification for it
but there's many many others right
but for not biometrics what happens is a
prior work has you know there's been a
fair bit of primer so they have either
looked at specific classifiers or like
nearest neighbors or decision trees and
random forests but there is nothing that
genetic and the challenge is that the
gradient based attacks you know they
don't really apply I mean you could
approximate things and then you could
look at the radiance but you know it's
not nice not as clean and what people
have seen and you know this is not a new
observation others have seen this as
well is that adverse adversarial
training you know you just saw this but
you know others have seen this as well
is that adversarial training does not
really work that well right so the
question is is there something generic
that be good okay so what we'll do is
next we will talk about generic attacks
then we will talk about kind of some
theory a limit object and then that will
motivate a generic defense okay so what
is a dynamic attack on non biometrics so
one key observation that we made is that
many nonparametric so things like you
know nearest neighbors or decision trees
or random forests they tend to be
piecewise constant on polyhedra right so
for example you know nearest neighbors
is piecewise constant on the water and I
sells K nearest neighbors for K nearest
neighbor there's something called that
order K bar and I diagram and these will
be piecewise constant on those cells of
this diagram decision trees are
piecewise constant within their you know
particular cells and so on and so forth
right and what we could do is we could
exploit this to come up with a region
based attack right so what we do is
suppose your polyhedra are p1 to PN
where the predictor labels are y1 to yn
right now what you do is you're given an
X you find the closest point on the
closest polyhedra that has a different
label right and that's your adversary
itself and if you try to solve it you
know it's a convex program and if you
manage to solve it correctly or you know
exactly then the solution is an optimal
attack right because you know by the
finish
it's optimal the solution will give you
an optimal attack the challenge is that
in many cases you may not be able to
solve it because you will have too many
polyhedra for example if you're looking
at K nearest neighbors there would be n
to the K polyhedra right so what you
could do is you could do some
approximation you have some heuristics
for ruling out some of the polyhedra so
something you could do is for example
you can only search over polyhedra with
a certain number of training points
closest to X so you look at X you look
at maybe it's 50 nearest neighbors you
look at all polyhedra that has these
neighbors otherwise you just don't look
at it at all
right and you know in this case you will
lose optimality of course that is you
know there might be another polyhedra
which has their closest aggressor in
example but it's still you know sort of
valid so and we call this the
approximate region basis okay so this is
you know fairly generic sort of attack
what about a defense okay so so to do a
defense yes we usually assume that the
adversary has access to the model yes in
this case a Crusaders have access that's
the white boxer
so now I also remember when we talked
about nearest neighbors we you know we
started talking about yes/no questions
that's optimization in Agoura
self-correct that actually exists I know
yeah so I think that is somebody in the
I don't know about optimization in
owaranai cell but we realize after you
know after we came up with this is that
people have looked at it in the context
of relu networks and what they do is cuz
radio networks even also look at you
know piecewise constant polyhedra right
so so anyway so the question is so you
know we talked about how things converge
to the Bayes optimal and the Bayes
optimal is the best thing ever for
accuracy right and now the question is
that what would you do for robustness
right is there a robustness added up to
the Bayes optimal which would be the bit
best thing for our robustness okay
so remember earlier in this talk we
talked about astuteness and the as
shortness of a classifier f at a radius
R was defined as the following so this
was defined as the fraction of points
where the classifier is accurate and
it's robust right so and the goal of
robust learning was sort of maximizing a
student's okay so let's try to see how
we can maximize our students right if we
can find the limit object that maximizes
a skewed less so you start out with the
robustness radius R right and you
started with a classifier f that
predicts and suppose you have a
classifier f which predicts label J in a
subset S sub J and is robust in that
subset right now since you are going to
be robust what you can say is that the
distance between pairwise distances
between your subsets is at least wiser
okay and then you can and if you have
this classifiers then you can also you
know write down it's a stiffness and
it's a sickness is the following you sum
over all labels J going from 1 to K you
integrate over X in S sub J probability
what is up
probability that the label is why the
label y is G in X sub J times mu of X DX
right so this is basically the accuracy
in the set a sub J and you sum over all
Sestak okay and this suggests the
following classifier you maximize so you
pick your subsets S sub J to maximize
this particular accuracy right subject
to the following constraint that the
distance the pairwise distances between
Si and SC is at least twice are when J
is not equal to i right and what you do
is once you have found those s i--'s and
s is you predict label j if your
distance from X S sub J is at most R
right so then you predict label J
otherwise you know okay so the thing to
observe is this is very much a limit
object much like the Bayes optimal right
because you need to know mu which you
never know and you need to know you know
this is basically your Etta
right you need to know the conditional
distribution which also you never know
right it's kind of a very complicated
thing so can you get a finite sample
approximation to this and you can buy
approximating S sub J by a sub set of
training examples right so what you're
gonna do is instead of this particular
objective which involves your ETA and
your meal you are going to look at you
know now your S sub J is a sub set of
your training examples
this becomes sum over you know X is your
training examples is in the set S sub J
1 the indicator of why I equal to G
right and you still have this condition
subjected to si distance between Si and
SJ is at least twice R right and if you
look at their you know if you stare at
it for a few for a couple of minutes
what this is is essentially this is the
maximal sub set of training samples
where points the different labels are at
least two are apart right so if you
stare at this for a while this is what
it will what will emerge now the
question is how to find those training
samples actually in the binary case this
will reduce to some sort of matching
problem and in the chaotic
it's not you know not matching anymore
it's some sort of graph independent set
but you can still have a pretty
algorithm right and the thing to notice
is that this is actually different from
what we talked about a trying at all you
know in our so this is a basically our
ICML paper so this is what we talked
about a little bit earlier and the
difference is that there's no confident
points right in bang at all what we were
doing is we were saving a bunch of
confident points and then we were
picking a maximal subset of the rest
here there's no confident points we are
just speaking the maximum subset so this
automatically suggests an algorithm
you'll find this maximal subset right
bets there two or more apart and then
you just build your favorite classifier
on it right you can build Mary's
neighborhood decision trees random
forests and so so that's and we call
that adversarial pruning okay so now I
can show you a few experiments and what
we were trying to understand is you know
of course how good is this region based
attack how effective is adversarial
pruning as a defense and you know does
it work for parametric as well okay so
and so how do we measure attacks because
we will evaluate a bunch of different
algorithms we are going to use this
notion of an empirical robustness right
so the empirical robustness is
essentially the distance to the closest
exam at Versailles an example produced
by a on F at X right so this is the
empirical robustness of an attack on a
at X and basically our attack metric is
going to be average empirical robustness
over examples where F is accurate so if
it's a small that means your attack is
better and for optimal attack this would
be the average robustness radius right
and average being taken over the
accurate points okay and we looked at
you know for different kinds of
classifiers you know nearest neighbors
two kinds of nearest neighbors decision
trees and random forests we looked at
nine data sets I won't you know bore you
with all nine and then we had a bunch of
attack baseline so the current I think
the current kind of state-of-the-art
black box attack is due to chang at all
and we looked at that for everything we
looked at for
new receivers we looked at direct
attacks and kernel substitution attacks
for decision trees we also looked at so
there's an attack by pepper at all four
decision trees we looked at that and for
Mira saber one nearest neighbor and
decision trees we use our exact region
based attack and approximate one is for
three nearest neighbors and random
forests so here are some results so what
you see here low means better right like
generally a low bar is not a good thing
but here low bar is a better means
better and what you see over here is
that the direct attack is kind of not
not that great for one nearest neighbors
and the Blackhawks attack is actually
pretty good the kernel attack is also
not that great and you know I'll being
exact is kind of the best and similarly
you know for three nearest neighbors
I'll be except proxies you know for this
particular data set our base rocks is
also the best for decision trees again
you know this is the best our be a is
the best and for random forests again we
are using RB aprox it's a little bit
better than the black box okay and so so
usually what we find is that our be a
exact turns out to be the best the IP
aprox we find it to be a mix on some
data sets it's better some data says
it's a little worse than the black box
anyway these are not too surprising
because it's doing an approximation and
you know if we did a more accurate
approximation it probably would have
been better
Maiden's it's not super surprising okay
so for Defense's what we would do is we
would look at the empirical robustness
of a defended classifier over the
empirical robustness of the undefended
classifiers
so that's that's kind of our defense
call so high defense score means the
defense of actually you know it's good
right and if you have like a standard
and defendant classifier then a defense
score should be one okay and here is
some you know here are some results so
here the high bar is a good thing like
here higher means better and what you
see
is here okay so for one nearest neighbor
we looked at undefended which is one
adversarial training ranks classified
which is our previous thing and also
adversarial proving right and what we
found overall is that these are mostly
comparable sometimes adversarial pruning
does a little bit better but these are
mostly comparable because they're doing
you know fairly similar things right
that's not for three nearest neighbor we
again look at undefended adversarial
training and pruning in this case you
know obviously adversarial pruning is
better for decision tree there is a new
robust decision tree attack by I think
by saying at all which just came out in
ice ml 2019 so we compare with them and
you know the results are mixed sometimes
they're better sometimes we are better
this is just one this is one dataset and
for random forests also it's a mix so
their defense also applies to random
forests it's also a mix it's common I
would say competitive not necessarily
better right and you know again here you
see that the trend has reversed RS is
better than adversarial pruning but you
know adversarial pruning is more general
right so here again that is an
adversarial community then finally
another question is you know what about
adversarial pruning for parametric
models right so there you know again we
looked at you know these are two
datasets we looked at logistic
regression and multi-layer perceptron
and what we find is again they're
adversarial pruning does help a little
bit but adversarial training as expected
is actually much better for that so so
in conclusion of experiments so what we
see is that the region based attacks are
you know either better than or
competitive with the prior work
adversarial pruning is you know either
better than in some cases are
competitive with existing defenses but
you know of course it's more general and
then it also helps parametric methods
but not as much as adversarial training
and the real question is you know what
is going on I think because you know
there is must be some fundamental
difference in which parametric and
nonparametric methods look at data and
which which results in this difference
and I think the real question is so in
conclusion we can show that K nearest
neighbors in general can be made robust
to adversarial examples video gain is
very large you can have some modified
nearest neighbors which is more robust
but the more interesting thing that we
see here is that nonparametric methods
are actually somewhat different from
pyro metrics when it comes to
adversarial examples and I think the
real questions for theoretical says you
know what and these are finally these
are my you know colleagues so Asia is
Asian and Yan these are my students and
each end is and so much as my colleague
ciders is a postdoc at UCSD so ish and
and so much are co-authors on our last
year's ICML paper about the nearest
neighbor proof you know nearest neighbor
stuff and cider see how animation are
[Applause]
so poppy finest is 90 that fiery
accident existence
[Music]
yeah they may not get this do then what
would happen is that you know you we
would never predict that later it's it's
not a good classifier but you will never
predict that perhaps you saw this thing
I missed it but this error cost that you
pay and that's an excellent question so
you do pay a cost in accuracy yes you're
absolutely right so that and and there
should be you're absolutely right that
there should be like an accuracy
robustness trade-off so the way we are
getting around this so it's very hard to
deal with by criteria stuff so the way
we are getting around it is we are just
looking at a stiffness right so we are
saying that we'll just maximize the
fraction where things are robust and
they are you know and they're actually
your understanding this right you're
considering 10 years neighbors and sub
metric as well as provisions in that
same method yes you accent you so the
necessary K you need for example if
you're doing like L 2 K nearest
neighbors and they're allowing for L
infinity perturbations does the K get
much larger or that is a very
interesting question so I believe there
was you know the one of the papers I
talked about the linear classifier
results so that's for them that is the
case right so they need more data for
robust optimization because for robust
generalization because the perturbations
are in different you know like the
natural metrics for gaussians is l2 and
then the perturbation is a little
infinity but we haven't looked at that
that's a very interesting open question
so
you're designing this like trade off
this thing gap between small home
Constantinian asymptotically more
robustness and the ADA not equal to zero
one is a really cool assumption here
graphics 1 0 or 1 1 nearest neighbors is
robust robust provided the decision
region first separated yes that is an
excellent point that is absolutely right
so going back to the initial motivation
for considering these problems has never
makes sense to compromise on the
accuracy to get more robustness okay
philosophical question I think it
depends to some extent on your
application or some cases you know but I
I okay so what I really think is what
makes sense is for you to say I don't
know okay so if you cannot predict
robustly you just say I don't know and
then somebody else looks at it
it's their way to enlarge the original
feature space so that you probably can
achieve better accuracy and also go
fasta this that is also not an excellent
question
so it is asking is is that a way to
enlarge the feature space you know I I
don't know I think for certain
applications that might be possible but
it really depends on that position
excellent question
this robust those questions you know
these are very very new people are just
starting to study it
yes so in the examples the metric is the
metric on the pixels then people have
also looked at more complicated
perceptual metrics especially so there's
some work on that as well so it is
efficient to get the maximal
Tango's together I honestly have to
so it's for binary labels it's a
bipartite matching problem and and if
your data is like different labels are
in triangle then what you are doing is
you're just removing the mine so let's
say you're eight hours let's say 0.25
right so then you know you have this
region
75% of plus and 25% - and what you would
end up doing with enough samples you see
we just removed all this reading Plus
which is good because that's the Bayes
optimal you know that's what the Bayes
optimal would do and that's what you
should
you know I don't know that's that's
another very good question we haven't
looked at it okay so thanks census this
was the last talk so thanks for coming
and for the people that asked for slides
an email will go out to all speakers in
a senator's life